what is your body count
i actually knew this was coming as well
you know all my days act cool so the the
honest answer is i don't know in it
what'd you say it's over 50
i look forward to seeing if the person i
date today will be willing to wait sex
is non-negotiable until the day of
marriage they gotta be fire they gotta
be sexy that's the first thing so i have
to be attracted to you to start in this
day and age a lot of people build
relationships off last i want the person
to know me for who i am rather than wash
down my pants i don't judge no women
that um sleep with me on the first date
because i don't blame them
best day
jeez my date for the day
sorry about that how are you i'm well
man how are you doing today i'm fine
thank you maggie you don't nice today
maggie i love your hair oh thank you
look nice as well did you want to start
yeah ladies first i reckon
so do you believe
women and men are equal in relationships
yeah
yeah yeah cool it's cool it's cool how
do you mean life so like do we have
equal roles
for me i feel like men can do it or and
women can do it all
i'm easy you know if it just so happens
that she's got an amazing high paying
job and i'm off work and i have to raise
the kids and so then so be it you know i
don't really believe in um gender norms
or whatever i just believe people are
flat out equal but yeah man what about
you
um i feel like um
no they're not equal like in general
there's certain abilities that a woman
can do for example like a mother's
instincts are to nurture what i mean
eternal instincts exactly and i feel
like so there's
certain roles that fathers play with
women playing i feel like you cannot
change that if that makes sense so i
feel like yeah it's not equal roles like
to me personally as i said um i would
prefer my man to be the one that
provides
i don't mind providing i feel like as
the woman i have to submit to the man
i feel like i have to submit but that
have to it's also willing yeah yeah
because you're willing to yeah yeah
despite what i want i'm still good with
with
with you the willingness is the bit i
agree with you i just don't think we
have to or you have to or you should
feel that you have to it's more of like
if you're happy to but you know
obviously again me naturally like i'm
alpha certainly like if i walk in a room
people know it boys know it ladies know
it's one of them one so naturally
i assert myself anyway so i think the
dynamic in a relationship would kind of
naturally form like that but i just
don't have that expectation i don't
think oh i have to because i'm the man
but but obviously if that's the way it
is then that's the way it is you know
i'm saying we're here i understand that
so
do you watch porn
what do you think the answer is
my gut reaction would have been no but i
actually believe i believe that you
probably do actually i believe i used to
okay right i used to um i don't anymore
reason being i feel like it's damaging i
feel like spiritually and and
psychologically it's damaging um clearly
you agree definitely so when i think of
poor i don't see the point of it it's
like movies it builds a false reality um
and false expectations that can never be
met like we don't see that the many
takes people take and things like that
and even when it came to porn like
i'm i'm straight but why am i watching
lesbian born um oh what are you when you
were watching point you weren't watching
i was watching lesbian posters like it
doesn't like it like it's like like the
whole context of it doesn't make sense
why were you only watching like girl at
go and go i don't know like i was
introduced to porn because i feel like i
was just left out so my like you need to
do it you need to watch it watch it
watch it so i was like missing out
before she ain't missing out there i
wasn't messing around
like that's that's what i'm saying this
fake hat that you're missing out on all
this sexual stuff that you're not really
missing out on like life is much more
than that
how about you do you watch for i'm
actually quitting you know i would say
yeah i'm quitting the car
everything you said i completely agree
with it in terms of like the
psychological damage especially to men
like because boys watch it young i used
to watch like
um amateur
that was the character cartoons no no no
no no that's anime that's anime that's
enemy that's like yeah the cartoon nana
is in amateurs like real people in it
how do you feel like it's
psychologically damaged you
wow
so
there was a period there a couple years
ago where it was affecting my
performance in the bedroom
it was it was it was part it was part it
was like part it was a factor it was a
factor
um so just just to be sure that's always
something that it kind of it took like
because of watching porn you find it
hard to be aroused in real life in real
life like
after a while because it was kind of
like i don't know it's just maybe
because you've seen it like you can
it's the fake valley it's the favorite
like it's easy to watch pool and get
excited boss you're not whatever be
disgusting yourself and move on with
your day but it's just like when now now
the real thing's in front of you it's
kind of like
it's not hitting this this is not the
same and i do feel like if you do remove
yourself from watching porn like you
that will eventually kind of it will
come back and it did
so my next question is what is your body
count
i actually knew this was coming as well
you know all my days act cool so the the
honest answer is i don't know in it
yeah what do you mean you didn't know
i don't have to explain that i love it
anymore i literally don't know anything
like um
like one i'm 26 years old what does that
mean
my age obviously oh i'm about to i'm
about to explain so obviously i'm 26
i've been sexually active since way
younger than i ever should have been to
to be honest and um
yeah i think when i broke up with my ex
four years ago four and a half years ago
i was extremely toxic i was i was in a
very like promiscuous stage not
necessarily promiscuous it was just it
was just like
i really
i wasn't all there in it i've really had
to grow i've had to grow a lot and i'll
be honest with you i regret
i don't even remember already all of
them like it's all it's just it's part
of a past life and that's being very
very real it's part of a past life that
i don't really care to think about
anymore um i've grown out of that stage
but that's the genuine answer i don't
know and it's it's far too high um it's
it's far too high would you say it's
over 50
um yeah yeah definitely definitely
messy nights i just blurred into one but
now i've grown up um and i'm glad you
know what i'm grateful i've gotten out
that stage because
i do i do believe that
a lot of men or a lot of people do need
a bit of a whole stage just just because
or even with women as well i feel just
just because
when they get into a relationship they
might feel that they missed out i don't
feel like i've missed out i'm done i'm
literally down so the person that i'm
with next i'm going to settle with what
i'm saying
okay that's what i'm looking forward to
but yeah what about yours then what's
your body come
zero
zero yeah very interesting yeah so
you're saving yourself a marriage yeah
okay
what's your thoughts on that
i respect it
yeah i mean you'd be willing to wait
me personally
probably not um if i'm if i'm being
honest because
but you said you're not missing out but
you're not willing to wait yeah because
it's not it's not about it's this the
two they're too extreme just like it's a
spectrum like i don't to be fair if i'm
gonna have a partner i would prefer them
to probably have a bit more experience
um just so i don't have to like you know
after they be
experienced sexually yeah
yeah
for me personally that wouldn't be ideal
really truly
okay but you can also find somebody
that's that's experience that isn't good
you can
you can to me the fact that you have sex
a lot it shows you don't really value it
because if you valued it you wouldn't
have it with
anybody what what about because i enjoy
having sex that's why i have a lot what
about that side of things
i don't know i just feel like if you
value something you don't have it as
frequent
yeah that makes it i know i get that i
get that i mean i i value certain foods
that steak i don't have that all the
time so i'll have that now and then but
the more you have steak the less you'll
value it yeah no that's oh i might get i
might get like what you call it not
complacent um you might lose
appreciation of it but i don't know sex
is a bit different you know um sex isn't
a mistake which i'm saying i think it's
a bit different obviously sex is
different with different people as well
very different experiences
so what's your
non-sexual turn-ons
[Music]
my non-sexual turn as being a christian
is a man that's prayed for what you pray
for
yes or no
because it's evil yes or no
i used to be very very religious in it
and i thought i don't know
my religion my
i feel like in in general in life we go
through a lot and i feel like when i
come to you of a problem i thought that
the first thing as a man i'm going to do
as i said like is to also provide a
solution you know what i mean so let's
pray about it i don't want to come to
you the solution is that you're just
talking a lot like let's first just give
this to one a little bit another section
turn on is just a a man that's gentle
did you get it you're gentle spirited
you're just you're just gentle at heart
that's a nonsexual one for me that's my
non-two sexual talents how about you
for me
someone who's ambitious um i really
really i'm attracted to someone who like
a woman who's got
a dream a vision um something whether
it's a business idea or just someone
where she wants to get to in life i
think that's for me that's a very like
an attractive quality that's like a yeah
it's like a damn you know she's a boss
i just wanted to ask you one last
question do you think there is going to
be a second date
you know what yeah
i think we've got different um core
values i believe yeah um and just in
terms of like the religion side of
things and those sex and things like
that a couple gender norms you would
make a good friend yeah and i hear that
do you fear nah i rate that
yeah very different but i think there's
certain similarities but yeah a bit
bigger yeah i just thought some of the
things that you were there some of the
things you were saying and i latched on
to but um in terms of like romantically
thin and this is
there's nothing
good
good friend man it's all good
[Music]
she was cool man she was good vibes um
she was pissing me off a little bit with
her facial expressions with jaromy but
other than that like uh other than that
she's yeah she was cool man we she she
seemed like she does seem like she had
good band like she'd be a good like
laugh like if i was to be honest i did
not feel like a date at all i felt i was
having a conversation with somebody i've
met the boston there wasn't much like
romantic i suppose like um
chemistry i feel for a person that
values sex in a relationship you have it
quite frequently sex is of value to me
and that's exactly why i don't have it
does that make sense it was interesting
to hear some of her opinions actually to
hear like what she where her mindsets
are especially at 21 as well i don't
feel sad for him i just feel sad on our
society that's how we view sex something
so
precious as between two people has
become so
it's nothing that i don't remember
i actually did go to a bdsm clock once
and it was the most horrific experience
ever i just ended up hanging out by the
buffet the entire night i'm eating
chicken and then i look to my left
somebody's getting
by the chicken